noch klarer äußern dass die Staaten in
Afrika sie wollen nicht paternalisiert
und bevormundet werden sondern sie
wollen eine Begegnung die diese diese
dieser Ausdruck ist ja echt schon
irgendwie inflationär Begegnung auf
Augenhöhe aber sie wollen tatsächlich
dass ihre Interessen gesehen werden und
das findet leider viel zu wenig statt
also das konkretes Beispiel
feministische Außenpolitik inhaltlich
bin ich da Chor sind viele Menschen da
Chor aber wenn man jetzt einen
Diplomaten mal dabei zusieht wir einem
Außenminister Afrikas erklärt was
feministische Außenpolitik ist dann ist
das schon relativ schwer das zu
vermitteln ich würde da kurz
widersprechen weil die südafrikanische
Regierung das ist ja gar nicht so
bekannt schon vor einigen Jahren das
Konzept feministische Außenpolitik
tatsächlich selber propagiert hat dass
und die haben das zum Beispiel als
Südafrika war gemeinsam mit Deutschland
damals nicht ständiges Mitglied im
Sicherheitsrat der UN da war es auch
Südafrika das genau dieses Konzept dafür
verfolgt hat